although I will say the most important
part about the Hawaii trip was that
gaunt and I are officially part of the
moped gang now yes I mean I I was the
one that got those boys into it sorry I
have now officially joined the moped
game yeah I mean part of the reason I've
become part of the moped moped gang was
because in the last month I went to
Vietnam oh yeah we didn't talk about
that yeah yeah it's so long I guess we
should go in chronological order right
we're way out of order though yeah we're
way out of order we went in reverse
order but yeah I uh I went to Vietnam
changed my life because
oh you're like a white guy
changed my life when I say that as a you
know already Southeast Asian and it's
been to uh Thailand a bunch of times my
life uh I am now part of the scooter
gang was that was that your first time
it was my first time right Vietnam
um so yeah I mentioned Paul
yeah it's funny because it's only like
an hour away from Bangkok so I don't
know why I've never been to Vietnam or a
lot of other Southeast Asian countries
that's that's what happens when
something is too close yeah you end up
never going because you always think
it's within reach yes exactly it's like
Japanese people never going to Korea
yeah it's like it's just right there
yeah I'll definitely go I'll go in here
that's fine yeah my entire life I'd
never gone on that trip for just an hour
even though it probably takes long to
fly to Hokkaido from here yeah but uh
yeah it was a very very short flight and
I you know I had a friend who was living
there so I was like yeah I'll come visit
you for the weekend first time in
Vietnam show me rounds
um so in my mind most Southeast Asian
countries are basically the same except
for Singapore Singapore Singapore's like
its own thing that's that's not real
southeast Asia right right
it's a friend with the the ridge house
yeah yeah boy
you know you guys have a good GDP you
know people follow the rules there
that's that's not real southeast Asia
man come on come on come on stop stop
faking guys stop playing chewing gum is
illegal yeah exactly right your streets
are clean yeah the privilege yeah you're
free to clean you got a good GDP what's
going on here you know that's not South
that's not the southeast Asia right now
but wow yeah so I mean what I will say
is uh yeah Vietnam is very very similar
to Thailand shocker
[Music]
so I I thought that I was prepared for
the scooter culture there because I
thought scooters were just everywhere in
Southeast Asia yeah um which they are in
Thailand as well but in Vietnam it is a
whole on a whole nother level it's it
was actually like [__] shocking to
see how many like the scooter to car
ratio which I got told I don't know if
this is true I got told it's like 80
scooters and motorcycles versus 20 cars
on the roads I don't know if that's true
but it definitely felt like the road now
yeah
uh and yeah just so my entire life my
entire life I was scared of Scooters or
scared of like I think I'd partly been
conditioned to not like to not get into
like the scooter culture and partly I
had some bad experiences as a kid uh
when I tried to learn how to ride a
scooter for the first time right uh and
uh I remember like when I was like seven
or something my cousin was like oh do
you wanna do you want to give it a go
didn't tell me anything and all I did
was just rev up oh no it just flew
forward it fell on me and I'm like I'm
never running a scooter again in my life
and also I grew up my parents were just
like you are not getting a scooter you
are never riding on scooters those are
dangerous do not do not do that we are
not a household that rides scooters here
so I I so my entire life my entire life
I'd just been conditioned to be afraid
of scooters
and anti scooter household but in
Vietnam you don't really have a choice
you don't really have a choice you are
getting on a scooter whether you like it
or not because even if you want to go
somewhere close by nobody really uses
cars for like uh their equivalent of
uber there which is grab everyone just
uses grab bikes and the first thing that
kind of sold me on this idea of you know
possibly riding a scooter in Vietnam is
a everyone wears helmets
what the [__] Thailand what the [__] I
mean like when you guys are in Thailand
how many people did you see wearing
helmets on motorcycles literally zero
zeros I don't even think they had seat
belts
dude half of them weren't even wearing
shoes yeah they're literally just
[__] free freeing the beasts and also
the hair just [__] flying out behind
them going at like 80 kilometers an hour
and they're just like yeah hell yeah on
the highway and I'm like all right well
yeah you're waiting to happen yeah I
mean I think Thailand has at one point
at one point was like the most dangerous
roads on the planet I believe that and
you know I I totally believe that as
well and uh so I thought okay this is
just normal in Southeast Asia going to
Vietnam blew my [__] mind because
they it made me realize oh people can
actually care about their safety and
follow the rules and uh well follow the
rules in terms of at least wearing
helmets even if you order like a grab
bike
um they every every motorbike taxi comes
with a spare helmet for the passenger
wow so I was just like if they can make
it work on Thailand make it work man
what's what's going on well I mean
throwing it back to the Hawaii thing as
well like you feel like I have to
negotiate in Thailand for the time now
it's an extra 20 bucks yeah yeah yeah
yeah what the [__] man give me the
helmet because like throwing it back to
the Hawaii thing like there's so many
like mopeds and scooters there as well
yeah no one was wearing helmets right
right even in Hawaii even in Hawaii they
weren't wearing helmets Yeah and I
remember because like when we rented our
scooters in Hawaii I was like I want the
helmet I want my safety and the guys
really the guy literally told us and
it's like oh that's good normally you
have to like really fight for my clients
to like wear helmets and they rarely do
they really do Jesus
um so yeah my first experience was
getting picked up by my mate at the
airport and he was like had a small
luggage on me and I was like where's the
car and he was like there is no car
welcome to Vietnam welcome to Vietnam
I'm actually traveling to a place and
bringing luggage yeah so
okay so I was like when I put the
luggage and he was like welcome to
Vietnam baby and so he just he he just
you know this was compared to compare it
to compared to some of the other [__] I
saw people putting on motorcycles this
was like this was tame but so he just
put out the front and I was like oh my
God are you safe with that and he was
like yep it's so it's all good this is
actually a pretty small luggage actually
oh my God uh and uh he just uh after we
dropped the luggage off back he kind of
like took uh took me around on uh took
me around on the bike and just went on
uh went on a tour of the entire city
varicious I don't know there's just
something freeing about exploring a city
on the back of a bike especially if it's
in Vietnam because there's I can't
really describe the feeling of going up
to the of like stopping out the traffic
lights and you are with an army of
schools you're the first one there I
have a new stop and then and then you
just hear the buzzing and then the bike
again
there is a certain frequency of the
Vietnam bikes where you just hear them
I've gone accidentally joined it back
again without realizing it yeah yeah it
kind of felt like when you you stop
online and you hear the buzzing as the
army of scooters just I I stop at the
light you look around you're surrounded
by scooters and then everyone's waiting
for the lights to turn green are you
just hear her you just hear an army of
I think it's like four guys on bikes
and then everyone goes off and nobody
crashes it was like playing real life
Mario Kart man you saw some people who
had the speed boost some people were
just like you know yeah yeah
and yeah that was just that was such an
awesome experience I was like I really
really want to try getting a scooter but
I don't know if I should I don't know if
I should you know my parents you make it
sound like Vietnam was only scootering
it was that's all you did that's I mean
any food I eat a lot of food but that
this that was kind of like the highlight
of my trip I think because I remember
the the entire time I was like I think
I'm gonna get a scooter but I don't I
don't know if my parents might be
happier I don't know if my parents are
going to be happy and then so after this
you know awesome bike tour that I took
with my mates we were just standing
outside
having a drink outside a bar and it was
like 4 P.M and I was just you know when
you're just like on the cusp of being
convinced of something yeah I was I was
like on that cusp and then as we're just
sitting down having a children just
enjoying the Vibes I just see I just see
this couple riding along and they're in
a bright red Vesper
and they just they just it was it was a
single Vesper driving down this road on
Vietnam and I could I could feel
something my brain just click
right on shoes
yeah
fast and I'm like I turned to my man I'm
like I'm getting a vesser I've just
decided it now I'm I rarely in my life
has something in my brain just clicked
that I know I'm going to make a
spontaneous purchase yeah but I I went I
went to him I was like as soon as I land
in Thailand the first thing I'm doing
I'm buying a Vespa and the first thing I
did was I landed in Thailand my parents
picked me up uh didn't even say hi I was
like Dad I'm buying a Vespa and he was
like what what what's what's going on
what you're buying investment you're
just here for another five days of like
I don't care that I've made my decision
I'm buying a Vesper I'm a changed man
I'll be honest uh even though I could
only write it for five days in Thailand
uh I'm sure I'll be back sometime but it
was it's waiting for you it was like it
was like a fish being like a fish being
introduced to water for the first time I
had realized that this was in my life
video yeah yeah discovers water for the
first time I I just realized just riding
the motorcycle and riding investment
around Bangkok it was it was like it was
in my blood this entire time I I had
tried to I tried to reject what was in
my bloodline but it's it just felt so
right and uh yeah I love how you went to
Vietnam in the past 20 minutes or you
were talking about as a [__] scooter
like this is everything this is
everything made almost great as well I
mean like
is Vietnamese food better than Thai food
or Italian oh no [__]
hey Liam say that yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry Vietnamese people you
guys need to put some chilies man you
know you need to put some chilies in
there take your helmet off man yeah okay
there's only so much Sriracha you can
put on [__] you know I need some I need
some actual chilies in my Cuisine yeah
but no Vietnamese food
sorry